President Trump insists he had no
problem with his White House Counsel
speaking to special counsel robert
muller Don McGann reportedly sat down
with Muller's investigators for 30 hours
in three separate interviews the
president quickly blasted the report and
called the Russia probe McCarthyism at
its worst
his legal spokesman Rudy Giuliani says
he's worried about Muller's motives
because quote truth isn't truth major
Garrett is at the White House he's been
talking with the Trump legal team major
good morning well good morning the
president's lawyers past and present say
they know and have known that White
House Counsel Don McGann spent hours and
hours with Special Counsel Robert Muller
and his investigators these lawyers say
they're not afraid about what McGann
told Muller about the firing of FBI
director James Comey and the White House
investigation and subsequent firing of
national security adviser Michael Flynn
but against time spent with Muller and
his evident candor have raised fears
here of a presidential perjury trap I'm
not gonna be rushed into having him
testify so that he gets trapped into
perjury Rudy Giuliani one of president
Trump's lawyers argued Sunday that mr.
Trump could perjure himself during an
interview with Special Counsel Robert
Muller because each side has a different
definition of motive evidence and truth
because it's somebody's version of the
truth not the truth he didn't have a a
conversation this truth I don't like I
know it isn't truth truth isn't truth
the exchange about provable truth came
as questions were raised about what
White House Counsel Don Magan at the
center of mr. Trump's most scrutinized
decisions dealing with Comey and Flynn
told Muller McGann gave Muller's
investigators a sense of the president's
thinking when he fired call me as well
as the move to ask Flynn he was also a
witness to mr. Trump's criticism public
and private of Attorney General Jeff
Sessions as well as White House debates
over whether to fire Muller current and
former members of the president's legal
team say they are aware of topics McGann
covered with Muller and are not
concerned began with a strong witness
for the president according to a story
in The New York Times that others on the
president's legal team dispute McGann
was reportedly surprised the president
gave him the green light and quote
feared mr. Trump was setting him up to
take the blame for any possible illegal
acts of obstruction unquote president
Trump attacked the New York Times story
saying he quote allowed Magan to talk to
Muller because he had nothing to hide no
one knows when Magan told Muller's and
investigators except those directly
involved the key issue here is of his
version of events would if President
Trump were to testify in any way
conflict or reinforce the recollections
or memos of James Comey that's one issue
what we do know is no charges have been
filed and Muller has not issued a
subpoena to testify to compel president
Trump's testimony something we might
expect if McGann in those interviews had
provided real evidence or some
bombshells that might implicate the
president John Major I want to ask you
about another separate investigation
that's going on by federal prosecutors
in New York into president Trump's fixer
or former lawyer Michael Cohen it's in
its final stages what do we know about
the charges they're considering well
they could involve bank fraud tax fraud
they could also involve failure to
report income from taxi medallions in
New York there could be some campaign
finance violations filed against Michael
Cohen all of this about either things he
undertook in terms of obtaining loans
work he did on behalf of mr. Trump
business and political and we are told
those charges could come by month's end
John and of course we're still waiting
for a verdict in the Paul Manafort trial
as well